จะ
เอา
ฮัลโหลสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูต้อง
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
นี่สบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะครูเอ๋มีน้ำส้ม
เห็นไหมฮู้น้ำส้มตำส้มกินมาก
หนังซ่อมราคาส้ม Soda คุณต้องหิวไหมคน
อื่นให้ดูอ๋อ
ตัวเองนี่หลอนแล้วก็ดูดกูต้องมีน้ำเปล่า
ค่ะเปล่าคุยก็มี
โหกูต้องมาๆมาบ้านครูเอ๋ครูเอกพาไปกินน้ำ
ส้มกินข้าวเลยได้ไหมร้ายมาสิมาๆๆบ้านกูก็
กลับบ้านใกล้ๆกันวันนี้อยู่บ้านคนเดียว
ใช่ไหม
วันนี้อยู่อยู่บ้านกับสามี 2 คน
ลูกชายครูต้อมออกไปข้างนอกออกไปตีกลอง
ต้อง
เป็นอะนักดนตรีหรอคะถ้าตีกลองอ๋อนักเรียน
คะลูกชายคุณต้อมหล่อมากแต่ว่าให้ฉันไม่
ชอบให้ดูรูปเขาใช่มั้ยดูได้ดูได้เอาลูกดู
ขอดูหน่อยได้ไหมคะเอาตัวเอกกูไอ้ Share
screen ก่อนบ๊ายบายๆนี่ๆเดี๋ยวกูต้องให้
ดู
หล่อมากนักเรียนขาหล่อจนครูคิดว่าคุณเอ
ยากเกิดช้าสัก 4  10 ปีอ่ะค่ะ
สามีแต่กี่หมด
Share  screen ให้ดูนะคะมี่หน้าให้วาง
แล้วนะครับ
เห็นไหมคะคู่แล้วเอ่อ
กูต้องขยายหน้าชัดๆอีกหนึ่งได้ไทยใหญ่
หน้าหรอๆก็เห็นละโอ้โห
มาใจละลายนักเรียน
เรียนครั้ง
อาจใจนะคะอันนี้ใจ
สีแดงดีกว่า
ใจน้ะเอ้าไม่แดง
หัวใจคู๋น่ะตอนนี้ไปเป็นเหมือนไอศครีม
โอ้โห
ไอศครีมเวลามีพระอาทิตย์ว่าจะ
ละลายลาลาลาลาลา
[เพลง]
เวลาก็บอกว่าเวลาเห็นอ่าอะไรนะผู้ชายเห็น
ผู้หญิงสวยหรือว่าผู้หญิงเห็นผู้ชายหรอก
ก็บอกว่าง่วงใดละลายเอารักเลยละลายไม่มี
แรงเดินแล้ว
อันนี้ลูกชายร้านซ่อมอายุไม่ๆจะ 17 แล้ว
ค่ะเด็ก
[เพลง]
7 ปีนะคะ
แต่ลูกชายครูต้อมนี่นะอ่าตรงกับที่คนไทย
เมื่อก่อนบอกใช่ไหมสูงสิงห์ Hand หล่อนะ
คะผิวสีแทนสูงหล่อ
High ไม่เราจะ
อาทิตย์มากมันจะเป็นวันเกิดเขาแล้วเราก็
จะ Happy  Birthday  To  You  1 วันเกิด
ก็เป็นที่คุณต้องบอกว่าไม่ไม่จัดงานใหญ่ๆ
แต่ฝากนอนใหญ่ๆเป็นงานในบ้านในครอบครัวนะ
ถ้ามีเล็กกูต้องก็เลยซื้อของขวัญให้เขา
ไอ้นี่แล้วก็ของขวัญให้กับรูปนี้ไม่เข้า
ไปถ่ายแบบคะเขาไปถ่ายรูปโปรไฟล์
ดู
โปรไฟล์สำหรับทำอะไรคะเอาไฟล์เอาไว้ให้
กับโมเดลลิ่งเวลาเสนองานขายโฆษณา
เป็นนายแบบ
ตอนนี้ยังตอนนี้ยังพ่อมีเซ้นส์โทรไปก่อน
แน่นอนอนาคตนักเรียนจะเป็นนายแบบแล้วก็
เป็นดาราได้เลย
คุยต้องเนี่ยตีกลอง
นั่งตีกลองราคาเราก็ร้องเพลงได้ไหมคะ
ร้องเพลงนิดหน่อยค่ะแต่ชอบตีกลองเอาตี
คลองครูเอ๋นะเคยเห็นรูปที่ลูกครูต้อมตี
กล่องนะค่ะเท่มาก
เวลาอันนี้ยืนยังไงอายแต่เวลาตีกองแล้วบ่
โหโอเคมากค่ะเวลาเขาไปตีกลองก็อาบแดดแดด
ร้อนมากร้อนๆๆๆแล้วก็แขนดำเลยนำไปสีแทน
เนยผิวทาครีมทาโลชั่นหน่อยไม่เอาไม่เอา
ไม่เป็นไรผู้ชายกูต้องผู้ชายนั้น
ผู้ชายตอนนี้ที่ผิวสีแทนมาแรง
มารอนานมากเรียกครูเอ๋ลูกชายกูต้องอายุ
ใกล้ๆจะ 17 ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็วันที่ 30
มิถุนายนนี้ค่ะอ๋อวันเกิดคุณหลานชายต้อม
ก็เลยพาไปซื้อของขวัญพาไปซื้อกางเกงตัว
นี้แหละ
เพลงตัวนี้นะค่ะขอซื้อแล้วก็ถ่ายรูปเลย
ทรายแล้วตอนที่ไปซื้อมันเล่นลูกไหมมัน
เล็กไปบ้างไม่ไปหรอพอดีไม่ค่อยดีโต๊ะตอน
นี้ฮะโอเคแล้วค่ะถามว่าตอนที่ไปซื้ออ่ะ
เขาก็ไปที่ร้านด้วยกันกับกูต้อมไปซื้อที่
ร้านแล้วก็เป็นลองกางเกงกูต้องเวลาไปซื้อ
มาตลอดเวลาซื้อกางเกงต้องเลือกอะไรก่อนนะ
เลือกไซส์ไซส์ไม่เลือกสี
สีด้วยสีเขาชอบสีเขียวขี้ม้าค่ะแล้วก็ก็
เลิกแบบด้วยไหมคะเลือกแถบสีแบบระวังอาจ
อนาถว่าเมื่อกี้สุดต้องบอกว่าต้องลองต้อง
ลองกูเอไม่กูต้องมีห้องมีให้ดูว่าเวลาเรา
เลือกได้แล้วใช่ไหมคะเราก็ต้องไปที่ห้อง
ลองแล้วเราต้องถามพนักงานไหมคะเราเลือก
ได้เสร็จเลือกได้กูเอกก็ถือไปเลยค่ะถือ
เสื้อผ้าไปที่ห้องลองเสื้อผ้าเห็นเลยล่ะ
คะให้ค่ะมองเห็นเลยค่ะแต่บางที่ก็มองไม่
เห็นนะคะเพราะว่ามีห้องเยอะมีเสื้อผ้า
แขวนอยู่เยอะก็ต้องถามพนักงานว่าบีห้อง
ลองมั้ยอือเพราะปกติถ้าเอกไปซื้อนะเอกจะ
ถามพนักงานก่อนว่าลองได้ไหมคะ
ลองใช่ไหมคะพ่อบางบางที่เขาไม่ให้ลองๆเขา
ไม่ให้น้องทำไม่ให้ลองเนี่ยไม่เหนื่อย
ส่วนใหญ่นะคะถ้าเป็นร้านเล็กๆก็จะไม่ให้
ลองค่ะมาแต่ถ้าเป็น Shop เป็นร้านใหญ่ใน
ห้างก็ลองได้
งั้นกูต้องก็ต้องถามเขาว่าห้องลองอยู่ตรง
อยู่ตรงไหนคะใช่ไหมให้มันมีเวลาไปซื้อนะ
คำถามเข้าห้องลองเนี่ยอยู่ตรงไหน
ทางโน้นค่ะทั้งนั้นค่ะตรงไปเลี้ยวขวาค่ะ
ตรงไปเลี้ยวซ้ายค่ะอ่ะอ่าๆค่ะหนังอยู่
ข้างหลังอะไรนะ
เชลล์ตรงนั้นนะคะเขาก็จะบอกนะคะ 9 ที่ทำ
ต่อเวลาเอาไปลองเอาไปกี่ตัวคะงูกูเองเวลา
เอาไปลองเอาไปลองได้เยอะหลายตัวแต่ที่กู
ต้องเคยเห็นนะคะมากที่สุดก็คือ 5 ตัวค่ะ
งานตัวนะคะขายแล้วเวลาไปไปลองอ่ะกูเอ๋นี่
เขาจะทำป้ายเอาไว้ให้เราแบบนี้ค่ะคุณเอ๋
ค่ะหมอให้เราถือป้ายเข้าไปอยู่ป้ายเข้าไป
เขาจะดูเขาจะดูก่อนว่าเราอีกเสื้อหยิบ
เสื้อหยิบกางเกงมากี่ตัว 1 ตัวก็เอาป้าย
ไป 1 ป้ายเขามีของข้าให้ไหมคะปากอ้าถ้า
เราถึงเข้าไปอยู่แล้วค่ะอ๋ออ้าเราถือ
ตะกร้ามีตัดมีตะกร้าแบบนี้น้องใช่กูเอง
ว่าง่ายๆ
คุยจะหวานเหมือนในผู้ต้องก็เหมือนค่าตัว
เองมีหนู
เดี๋ยวนะคุยแล้วว่าไม่ค่อยเหมือนแล้ว
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้บ้านใหม่โอเค
หน้ากากปลาส่วนใหญ่ก็สีแดงด้วยเนาะใช่
ปากกาแบบนี้นะคะนักเรียน
อา
หมัดนี้
แล้วก็มีหูแบบนี้ขายค่ะ
อันนี้จะเป็นหูจะกล้าแล้วก็เอาตะกร้าใน
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตเลยเหมือนกันใช่มั้ยใช่
ร้อนเอาเสื้อผ้าเอาเสื้อเอากางเกงน่ะมา
เสื้อ
กางเกง
กระโปรงม่วง
กระโปรงใส่ลงตะกร้าใช่ค่ะก็ใส่ไปมีจะเข้า
ห้องรอมีมีรอคอยเช็คคอยตรวจว่ามีกี่ไงเขา
จะถามเขาแล้วก็จะดูในตะกร้าค่ะว่ามีเสื้อ
ผ้าอยู่กี่ตัว
5 เขาจะ 1 ตัวก็เอาป้ายไป 1 อัน 5  5
ตัว 5 ตัวก็อะ 1 ป้ายจะเขียนว่า 5
ได้เหมือนกันป้ายก็เขียนแยก 5 ไม่ใช่ 1  2
3  4  5 ไม่ใช่นะคะยกตัวก็เอาไปเบอร์
หนึ่งไปเบอร์หนึ่งไม่มีสองตัวก็เอาป้าย
เบอร์ 2 มี 3 ตัว
เอาไปเบอร์ 3  4 ตัวป้ายเบอร์ 4 มี 5 ตัว
ก็เอาป้ายเบอร์ 5 ไปนะคะโอเคเข้าใจอีก
อย่าง 5 ป้ายนะป้ายเดียวคู๋ๆอย่างในเวลา
ที่เราลองเสื้อผ้าเรียบร้อยแล้วหมอเขาก็
ไปกล้าออกมาคืนเขาเอาป้ายออกมาคืนเขาด้วย
นะคะเนี่ยไปคืนเขาก็จะนับเสื้อผ้าว่าตรง
ไหมได้ค่ะแล้ววันนั้นน่ะกูต้อมลูกชายไป
ลองกางเกงอ่ะเอาเข้าไปกี่ตัวคะ 3 ตัวค่ะ
ตัวสีเหมือนกันไหม
สีไม่เหมือนกันแบบเหมือนกันไหมคะแบบ
เหมือนกันขนาดเหมือนกันนั้นอาจไม่เหมือน
กันแล้วมีขนาดไหนบ้างคะที่เอาเข้าไปคุยลบ
ตอนนี้ให้ก่อน
ไปนกอันนี้ก่อน
มาเป็นกางเกงไซส์นี้ไปที่รูปลูกชายดีไหม
คะได้ค่ะ
แล้วก็มีอ่ะอ้ะสีไม่เหมือนกันแต่ว่าสมมติ
คุยว่าเป็นกางเกงเนาะอะ
มี
ภาวะสีคู๋มีไม่เยอะอ่ะอันนี้ขนาดอะไรนะคะ
S
onigo ต้องเอาไป Five  m  1 ตัวเกมนะเอก
ก็ไปใส่ S เลย
m ราคาไซส์ต่อไปไซส์อะไรคะ size  L ค่ะ
เออคนไทยก็พูดใช้เนาะใช่คนไหนไม่พูดขนาด
นะพูดจริงบอกขนาดแต่ว่าตอนนี้เราพูด size
ไว้ละเป็นทับ like ภาษาอังกฤษนะคะได้กว่า
ค่ะ L ใช่ไหมค่ะ
size  M  size  L  size  L  R ขนาดต่อไป
แล้วต่อไปเนี่ยกูต้องก็เอาอีกสีหนึ่งค่ะ
เป็นเป็นสีสีกรมธาตุสีน้ำเงินหาอ๊อดสี
น้ำเงินนะคะสีน้ำเงิน size  M หมอ
พวกมันมี 2 ตัวสีน้ำเงินนะคะ
M สีเขียวนอนนิพ่ายสีเขียวตัวที่เขาใส่
อยู่นี่เลยวันนี้ก็เขียว L มหาๆไปค่ะ TA
เรื่องมีอยู่ว่ามีอยู่ว่าอะไร
เขาลองใส่กางเกงทุกตัวเลยแล้วชอบตัวไหน
ฮ่าๆเขากูต้องหมักคิดว่าเขาต้องไป size  L
แม่
เขาใส่ไซส์ L แล้วเขาบอกว่ามันใหญ่เกินไป
ขอถ้าใหญ่คือหลวมมันเซื่อกูเองเสื้อกู a
นะใหญ่ก็หลวม
หลวงช่วยคุณต้องรวมมั้ยไม่หลวมค่ะขี่พอดี
พอดีเสื้อใหญ่นักเรียนถ้าให้ดูเอาเสื้อ
ใหญ่นะคะอยากตายได้อีกนะคะพ่อก่อน
ค่ะมันใหญ่เกินไปเขาบอกครูต้อมว่า size  L
ใหญ่เกินไปง้อ
แล้วไซส์ M นะคะเขาบอกว่ายังไงเขาก็ใส่
ไซส์ M แล้วเขาก็บอกว่าโอเคแม่พอดีพอดี
อ่ะมีคำถามตอนที่ไปซื้อเวลากี่โมงคะตอนไป
ซื้อเวลา
5 โมงเย็นแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋ 5 โมงเย็นนะคะ
17:00 น
17:00 นกินข้าวหรือยังคะกินข้าวเรียบ
ร้อย
ถ้ากินข้าวเรียบร้อย 17:00 นโอเค
เกิดครูเอกกำลังคิดไงว่าถ้าซื้อขั้นตอน
ที่หิวข้าวน่ะอ๋ออยู่ข้าวเนี่ยโปท้องยัง
แหมบถ้าซื้อพอดีกินข้าวเสร็จท้องใหญ่ขึ้น
ออนไม่ ok
good ลูกชายกูต้องตัวเล็กตัวผอมค่ะอาไม่
กินข้าวหรือไม่กินข้าวก็เท่ากันเลยเขาไม่
แหวนคู๋น้องกูเองอ่ะยังไม่กินข้าวเนี่ย
เล็กๆคนกินข้าวแล้วโอ้ขอ Hyundai ขึ้นคุณ
ต้องครูเหมือนกันเป็นแก๊สไง
[เพลง]
เสร็จแล้วเขาก็เลยโอเคอ่ะเอาไซส์ M นี้นะ
คะสิริค่ะ
ใช้ size  M กลับมากูต้องก็เอาไปจ่าย
ตังค์
ตกลงซื้อไซส์ M โอเคกูต้องจ่ายตังตอนที่
จ่ายตังค์คู๋เขาก็จะใส่ถุงให้นี้นะคะตรง
นี้ค่ะถ้าไปโทรมุม
ใส่ถุงไม่ได้ห่อของขวัญใช่ไหมคะใช่ไม่ได้
ห่อค่ะสมมติเป็นกางเกงนะคะเอากางเกงใส่
ถุง
ไม่ต้องขอเนาะรูปเห็ดแล้วใช่ๆไม่ต้อง
เซอร์ไพรส์ครูเอชอบนะคุณต้อมริบบิ้นแทน
นักเรียนคะขอของขวัญเนี่ยของขวัญน่ะ
หลวงพ่อของขวัญอ่า
ใช่แต่ว่าเคยไม่ซื้อเสื้อผ้าให้เพื่อนวัน
เกิดแล้วปรากฏว่ากล่องแล้วก็กระดาษกระดาษ
ที่มีดอกไม้นะฮะ
แล้วก็ริบบิ้น
ริบบิ้นตัวนี้ประมาณ 300 บาท
กระดาษอีกเท่าไหร่ 100 บาทคะแล้วก็มี
ริบบิ้นตัวนี้อีก
คืนริบบิ้นกับกระดาษรวมแล้วประมาณ 4  500
บาทสมไม่ในอ่ะสามร้อยบาท
ครูเอกก็เลยเวลาซื้อของขวัญให้เพื่อนให้
หลานตอนนี้ไม่เอากล่องของควายเอาไม่
ประหยัดเงินแต่ถ้าขอฟรีโอเคอ๋อกินข้าขอ
ฟรีก็จะมีที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะมีตรงนี้มีอะไรนะ
เป็นทรัลเอ็มโพเรี่ยมว่าจะมีชื่อแต่ถ้า
เราไม่เอาเอากระดาษสวยเอาริบบิ้นสวยๆที่
อันนะจะแพง
ต้องจ่ายเองๆตอนนี้ไข่ไม่ห่อค่ะใส่ถุงและ
ไม่หอมคุณต้องก็เอาใส่ถุงเอาใส่ถุงเสร็จ
นะคะเขาก็จะมีใบเสร็จแต่ผู้หญิงที่เรียก
ว่าใบเสร็จห่าต้องปิดยี่ห้ออะไรก่อนก็
เป็นใบเสร็จแล้วล่ะที่ห้ออะไรอ่ะ
นะปิดเอาไว้ดีในใบเสร็จก็เก็บเอาใบเสร็จ
ใส่ถุงมา
ขับรถตึงตึ๊งกลับมาบ้าน
ชาย
ใช่กับกลับมาเขาก็ไม่เจอค่ะดีใจชอบมากเขา
กลับมาเจอกับพ่อเขา
เขาก็อยากจะหวดจะโชว์ว่าเขาซื้อกางเกงมา
ใหม่
เขาก็หยิบกางเกงออกมาจากถุงจ้าอะก็เอามา
ใส่เอาให้พ่อดูบอกพ่อดูไหมเป็นยังไงเนี่ย
สวยไหมสวยไหม
ใส่เสร็จปุ๊บเขาก็นั่งนะ
เค้ายืนใช่ไหมไม่สวยไม่สวยมั้ยล่ะเขาก็
นั่ง
ก็นั่งเป็นยังไงเกิดอะไรอยู่เฮ้ยขากางเกง
มันเลยกูเอ๋
นั่งไม่ได้เอาเหรอ
โอ้โอโอไซต์ M มันเล็กเกินไปคือคือบริเวณ
นี้ใช่ไหม
ตรงนี้ไอ้ก่อนนะตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะที่นั่น
ชายใช่เพราะว่าตรงเอวสานาง fifth เวลา
นั่งนำมันต้องดึงขึ้นมาได้นิดนึงมันนั้น
อ่ะดึงขึ้นมาได้นิดนึงแต่ถ้าดึงให้กิน
นั่งไม่ได้นะ
ไม่ได้
หนูต้องก็เอาละสิทำยังไงล่ะทำยังไงล่ะอ่ะ
กูต้อมได้ยินนะคะจำได้ว่าพนักงาน
มีผู้ที่ฟังว่าค่ะ
บ้านที่เขาเอาบินเอาใบเสร็จนะค่ะเข้าไป
เสร็จใส่ถุงให้อ่ะเขามีเขียนเอาไว้ในใบ
เสร็จด้วยนะคะเขียนว่าเขาเขียนว่า
เปลี่ยนได้เปลี่ยนเกลียดหรือแรง
เปลี่ยนได้ 8 คืนไม่ได้อ๋อก็คือต้องเอา
กางเกงไปที่ร้าน
แล้วก็เปลี่ยนไซส์จาก M ใช่ไหมคะ
size  M
เอาไปคืนเปลี่ยนเป็นไซส์ L
อาจจะเต็มน่ะเอาไปแล้วก็เอา L กลับมาใช่
มะแต่ต้องยังไม่ตัดป้ายด้วยหรือเปล่าไม่
ตากถ้าไม่ตัดมาที่กางเกงจะมีป้ายราคาใช่ 5
หลักแอบถ่ายกูต้องจำไม่ได้นะในในปีหน้ากู
ต้องก็ไม่ได้อ่านแต่คิดว่าเปลี่ยนภายใน 7
วันชื่อปกติต้อง 7 วัน 7 วันหรือ 15 วัน
15 วันแล้วแต่ร้านค่ายแล้วแต่ร้านบาง
ร้านก็บอกว่า 7 วันบางร้านก็ 15 วัน 5
วันค่ะน่านเข้าไปเลยไหมคะวันนั้นหรือว่า
เปลี่ยนวันห้างปิดค่ะ
ออก
นอน
ฝันดีนะที่ยังไม่ตัดป้ายอ่ะบางคนก็ตัด
ม่ายใช่ก็ลูกชายกูต้องก็แบบ
เปลี่ยนได้ไหมเปลี่ยนได้ไหมหน้าเปลี่ยน
ได้ไหมอยู่ในใจ
ต้องงอนนึงอ่ะเด็กๆนะน้อง 17 เองอุตส่าห์
ดีใจดีใจดีใจหรออ้าวเข้าไปเปลี่ยนเอ่อ
เอ็นดูนาง
แม่ยังไงดีอ่ะพรุ่งนี้ต้องยังไงดียังไงทำ
ยังไงอ่าแล้วแห้งไกลจากบ้านได้คุณต้อง
อาบประมาณ
6  7 กิโลค่ะอ๋อค่ะนะกูไม่ไปแล้วกูต้อง
วันนี้ห้างปิดแล้วแต่ว่าแล้วลูกไม่สบายใจ
คุณต้องบอกยังไงอ่ะกูต้องบอกว่าไม่เป็นไร
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้แม่ขับรถเอาไปเปลี่ยนให้
ตลาดต้องไปไม่ต้องไปค่ะ
กูต้องไปกับพ่อเขาสองคนได้ค่ะค่ะเพราะว่า
ลูกโรงเรียนใช่ไหมใช่
เลยค่ะเอาเป็นเกมเข้ามานะคะหนูก็เอาใส่
ถุงค่ะ
ไปถุงกูต้องก็ต้องไม่ลืมว่าเอาบิลไปด้วย
อ๋อและก็เอาใบเสร็จแล้วค่ะไปถุงไปด้วยค่ะ
แล้วก็ไปที่ห้างเอาที่ร้านให้ถึงแล้วก็
ต้องไปบอกเขายังไงรู้ไหมคะบอกว่ายังไงคะ
ตอบถูกต้องก็อ้างแกะออกมาอ่ะ
มาเปลี่ยนกางเกงค่ะ
ที่ร้านเขาบอกว่ามีร้านเขาก็ถามว่า
เปลี่ยนสีหรือเปลี่ยนไซค์คะคุณต้องบอก
ว่าเปลี่ยนไซส์ค่ะเปลี่ยนไขมันเล็กพี่มาย
เรียนซ้ายจาก m  m  L ค่ะอันนี้เขาก็ถาม
กูต้องอีกว่าคำว่าอะไรมีใบเสร็จมาไหมคะ
ทำให้ดู
นี่ค่ะใบเสร็จ
หายเขาๆไปเป็ดไปดูดูๆๆ
โอ้นี่ค่ะรอสักครู่นะคะ
เขาก็ต้องว่าไม่คุยต้มไปหยิบเองได้เลย
ป้าเขาไม่ได้ไปหยิบให้ก็ต้องไปหยิบเองใช่
ค่ะเพราะเขาคิดว่ากูต้องรู้อยู่แล้วแล้ว
ก็น่าจะเร็วกว่าค่ะหากูต้องโอเคโอเคๆกู
ต้องไปเดินไปแล้วก็หยิบไซส์ L มาแล้วก็
ถามพนักงานว่าข้างง่ายๆต่อคะ
เขาเขาบอกว่าไปที่เขาก็แคชเชียร์ได้เลย
ค่ะ More  The  Asia เขาก็แสกนให้อ้าง
เรื่องเปลี่ยนป้ายกูต้มซอยถือ size  M
ตัวเก่าหาคะแล้วก็ไซส์ L ตัวใหม่แล้วก็ใบ
เสร็จไปด้วยกันแล้วก็ใบเสร็จไปที่
แคชเชียร์ต่อทุกทีเขาก็
กี่โอเคอะไรอ่ะนักเรียนทำอะไรไม่รู้
จะแก้รหัสหน้าเค้าจะมีอะไรแล้วเป็นรหัส
ใช่ไหมคะเขาต้องแก้ว่าตัวไหนขายแล้วตัว
ไหนเอามาเปลี่ยนเขาแก้วๆคันในระบบ TT ข้อ
มูลในระบบเขาเขาก็โอเคค่ะแล้วเขาก็เอา
ไซส์ M หลักไปแล้วก็เอาไซส์ L นะคะใส่ถุง
ในถุงกลับมาให้
มันบนใบเสร็จเนี่ยเราก็คืนกลับมาให้กู
ต้อมเขาก็ให้กูซ่อมอ่ะเป็นชื่อในกระดาษ
ของของพนักงานอ่าคือจะถ้าเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยน
ได้ครั้งเดียวเนาะนี่ก็เปลี่ยนไหมครั้ง
นึงค่ะใช่เอาไปเสร็จแล้วกลับมาเปลี่ยนอีก
อันนี้ไม่ได้แล้วนะพอแล้ว
เปลี่ยนได้ 1 ครั้งนะคะใช่ค่ะโอเคนะกู
ต้องก็เลยโอเคเอากางเกงกลับมาให้ลูกชาย
ได้อาบน้ำอยากนะ
เก่งมากคุณแม่แล้วค่อยกลับมาจากโรงเรียน
พ่อแม่แม่เปลี่ยนได้ไหมเปลี่ยนได้ไหมอ่ะ
อ่าน่ารู้จักบอกว่าเปลี่ยนไม่ได้ลูกแกล้ง
ลูกชายถามว่าแล้วเสียตังค์อีกหรือเปล่า
อ่าง้อลูกชายคิดว่าเวลาไปเปลี่ยนต้องจ่าย
เงินเพิ่มอาแม่ก็เลยบอกว่าไม่เสียตังค์
แล้ว
ใช้ก็ดีใจเย้
ลองใหม่ไหมคะลองใส่ลองค่ะเขาลองใส่กางเกง
ใส่กางเกงต้องปรับให้คุณพ่อ
เคยรอเลยโอเค
นะคะครูเอ๋อีกไม่กี่วันเนาะอีกประมาณ 4
วันก็วันเกิด
ให้สุดบอมนะคะ
ได้ของขวัญก่อนดีใจใส่แล้วก็เพราะนะหาย
คู่เอกเคยไปเปลี่ยนสินค้าไหมคะ
กูเอกจะลองก่อนรองจนใส่ได้นะคะแต่เคย
เหมือนกันที่ตองไปซื้อมาหากูต้องไปที่
หน้าว่างๆได้ไหมคะอันนี้ห้องลองกูเอกก็จะ
ทองไปลองลองแล้วคุณเอกมีปัญหาน้องใส่ไม่
ค่อยได้
เร็วครูเองไม่มาตรฐานอ่ะกูต้องมาขอกระดาษ
หน้าว่างค่ะมาค่ะหน้าวางก็คือแบบนี้ค่ะ
อ่า
เวลาไปซื้อกางเกงอ่ะกางเกงอ่ะนับขาเขาจะ
ยาว
เอกขาสั้นไงกูเอกจะต้องกลับ
กางเกงยาวแต่เราขาสั้น
วันที่ใส่แล้วโอเคไม่โอเคอย่างเงี้ยจะมี
อยู่ครับเนี่ยครั้งหนึ่งอาอ้าอ่ะไม่ซื้อ
ซื้อแล้วแม่ค้าเขาไม่มีห้องลองไม่ใช่ใน
ห้างราคาท่านเล็กเขาไม่มีห้องสำหรับรอง
เขาก็บอกว่าเปลี่ยนได้นะ
ได้กูเอกก็ซื้อมาอ่ะคือไม่รู้ว่าเยวตัว
เองจะมีเอวนักเรียนเต็ลมีไหมเอวมีสิ
อันนี้เร็วมันใหญ่ขึ้นอ่ะตอนไปซื้อหน้าก็
ซื้อเร็ว
ซื้อเร็ว 20 ก่อนนะคะนักเรียนมาก่อนเอง
ว่าเล็กๆ
ซื้อเอว 20 ยืดสุด 26 นิ้ว
เพราะว่าเยวเอ๋จะอยู่ที่
25-26  5 ก็ซื้อเอว 26 นิ้วมาอ้าว
พระเอกก็เว่ามันเล็กอ่ะแต่พระเอกก็คิดว่า
มันเล็กเพราะตอนนั้นเดินเดินๆยังไม่ได้
กินข้าวเวลาเวลาซื้อกางเกงอ่ะคือเร็วนะ
25-26 ไปเอกเรื่องกางเกงประมาณ
27-28
นิ้วใหญ่พึ่งอยู่ใหญ่ขึ้นนิดนึงเพราะว่า
วันชีเวลาปวดท้องและท้องมีแก๊สมันจะใหญ่ๆ
อ้ะมันซื้อเร็วใหญ่ไว้เอกก็บอกเขาว่าน่า
จะใส่ 27-28 อ่ะแม่ค้าก็มีสายวัดแล้วก็
วัดเขาก็บอกว่าอุ้ยเอว 25
ครึ่งไหมถ้าจำไม่ผิด 25 ขึ้น
อ่ะแต่ตอนนี้ยี่สิบห้าครึ่งไม่มีมี 26
เอา 26 ไปเถอะ 27 ใหญ่ไปอ๋อ
และก็
26 คิดว่าใส่ไม่ได้อ้ะหือมันไม่ได้เพราะ
เวลาเวลาที่เรามีมีแก๊สมีอะไรมันจะใหญ่
ขึ้นเค้ากินข้าวเยอะๆแล้วตอนนั้นเราเดิน
มาเดินๆอย่างไม่ได้กินข้าวท้องมันก็ขอ
แฟ๊บเขาก็บอกใส่ได้ถ้าไม่ได้กลับมา
เปลี่ยนได้
ป้ายเนี่ย
มีป้ายห้ามกัดละ
ก็โอเคงั้นก็เอามาซื้อของตัวกูซ่อม
2 ตัวเลย
สีค่ะเอาไว้ให้สีครีมสีครีมก็สีคล้ายๆสี
และเหมือนแบบนี้ค่ะนักเรียน
ไปๆอันนี้สีเหลืองเหลืองใช่ไหมแต่จะอ่อน
กว่านี้นิดนึงกับสีดำนะคะสีดำๆไปขอและก็ 2
ตัวราคาพ่อกลับมาบ้านก็ลองใส่เป็นไงคะ
กลับมาบ้านนี้จริงอิ่มแล้วไง
ขอใส่โป๊ป
รึ
มันก็ได้อยู่นะพูดห้องใบ้หรอวะมันเหนื่อย
ขอ
วันที่ดีไม่ดีวันนี้ก็เหนื่อยเอ่อตอนนั้น
ครูเอ๋อยู่กับเพื่อนเนาะก็บอกโอ้ยไม่ได้
อ้ะสายอัสมะห์คู๋
ก็คิดว่าพรุ่งนี้จะไปเปลี่ยนไหมถ้าว่า
เอ๊ยไม่ต้องเปลี่ยนไปวิ่ง EXO สายโอโห้
[เพลง]
ลงเหลือ 20  4
ป้ายใช่ไหมครับถ้า
ให้เอวลงเนี่ยเหลือ 24 จะได้ใส่เอางู a
ไปวิ่งไหมคะโอ๊ยก็เอกก็เชื่อเพื่อนาก็ได้
ค่ะแต่เปลี่ยนเนี่ยต้องภายใน 7 วันใช่ไหม
อ๋อ 7 วันจากผู้ต้อมกูอาจจะเอา EL  mar
24 ใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่คะ
7 วันไม่น่าได้ไม่ได้
ขอโทษนะ 7 ปียังไม่ได้เลยค่ะ
มันเอง 27 ปีก็ยังไม่ได้
ให้นอนจ้าได้ผู้หญิงเอวมันจะใหญ่ขึ้น
เรื่อยๆใช่ไหมคะ
ต้องต้องออกกำลังกายเท่าไหร่ต้องหยุดกิน
แล้วก็ผอม
ก็เลยกางเกง 2 ตัวนี้กูต้องคุยไม่ได้ใช้
งานเพื่ออ้าวแล้วไม่เอาไปเปลี่ยนเนาะไม่
ได้เปลี่ยนเพราะว่าเพื่อนบอกว่าเอ๋อีกนิด
เดียวเอง x30 ผมกำลังกายให้เอวเล็กๆตัว
เล็ก
ก็กำลังกายไม่ช่วยไม่สวยไม่ทันแล้วมันถึง
7 วันให้ 7 วันเท่านั้นก็เลยไม่ได้ใส่
แล้วก็ให้เขานี่ให้คนตัวเล็กๆไปอ่ะเพราะ
ว่าจะเก็บเอาไว้นะเก็บไว้ดูชอบจังเลยดูดู
1 ปี 1 ปีแล้วก็ให้ให้คนอื่นไปค่ะ
ไม่ได้ 1 ปี L ก็ใหญ่ขึ้นไม่ได้เล็กลง
แล้วกูแอบอยู่เนี่ยร้านบางร้านที่เป็นลาย
เล็กๆที่บอกว่าไม่มีห้องลองอ่ะค่ะเขาก็จะ
มีกระโปรง
กับใส่เป็นกระโปรงแบบนี้สิไหนใช่เป็น
กระโปรงต้มใส่ตรงนั้นเลย
[เพลง]
เป็นที่เขาเรียกว่าผ้าถุงอาหารเป็น
กระโปรงยื่นแบบนี้ใช่ค่ะแล้วเราก็ใส่ตัว
นี้แล้วก็เอากางเกง
อ่าใส่ข้างในอีกทีนึงใช่ไหมคะให้เดี๋ยว
นี้แบบนี้มีเยอะมากๆอ่ะล้านวันนี้ครูเอ๋
ซื้อกางเกงเอวยืดค่ะ
สนุก
ขยายหาได้เล็กได้
เอวยืด
ไม่ดีนะผมต้องมันนี้เราก็จะไม่ระวัง
เอวให้เราก็จะขยายขึ้นแล้วนะถ้ามันแค่นี้
เราจะได้ออกกำลังกายไม่มันดีมากนะครูเอ๋
เวลาที่เราไปกินบุฟเฟ่เอวยืดเหรอคะ
มันก็จะยืดไปอีกอยู่ดี
กินบุฟเฟ่ได้เยอะๆกูไม่คิดจะพร้อมแล้วค่ะ
ไม่ต้องแบบนี้น่ารักเพลงเราสบายใจแล้วนะ
คะเราต้องซื้อที่เราใส่แล้วเราไม่อ๋อแน่ะ
We  are  a บัดนั้นไม่เอาอ่าหยิบ
บุฟเฟ่ต์ไม่ได้คุณต้องใช้เฟอ่ะกูชอบนะแต่
ว่ากินได้ไม่เยอะ
อันนี้ชอบกินไม่เยอะไม่ไม่
คุ้มคู๋เอกก็ไม่ชอบบุฟเฟ่ค่ะเพราะกินได้
นิดหน่อยเหมือนกัน
นะก็เรื่องของการเปลี่ยนเสื้อผ้าเนาะซื้อ
แล้วมาใส่แล้วไม่ไม่พอดีก็เวลาซื้ออย่าไป
ตัดนะคะบางคนไปตัดอะราคาแล้วป้ายราคาป้าย
ราคาตัดป้ายราคาออกกอล์ฟเปลี่ยนไม่ได้
เจวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะนักเรียนแล้วพบ
กันใหม่คลิปหน้านะคะใช่ค่ะค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ
ผู้เองดีค่ะคุณต้อมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนที่
ยังไม่บายน